Good afternoon, everyone. I think we'll go ahead and get this session started.
My name is Chris Lee. I'm a faculty member at the Fred Hutchinson
Cancer Center, a cancer epidemiologist, and I'm delighted to have the
opportunity to chair this session on precision screening,
where we'll be exploring opportunities to enhance the benefits of cancer screening.
So I'm going to just give a very brief introduction to this session.
In the cancer screening world, we continue to use largely a
one-size-fits-all approach
that's generally just based on an individual's
age. We do know that both over-diagnosis as well as
over-treatment are well-established consequences of
screening that we hope to try to overcome, but we also know that screening can miss
aggressive, often fast-growing tumors.
And so really the question that this session has been designed to try to
address is can we make screening both more efficacious and more
efficient through implementing risk-based precision screening?
So we talk a lot about precision oncology, but how can we apply that same
sort of lens of precision to the concept of screening?
So we have three speakers today. We'll start
off with Dr. Graham Colditz from WashU in St.
Louis, who'll be talking about his work related to breast cancer screening.
I will then give a presentation on some of the work that we're doing on development
of novel blood-based biomarkers, and then we'll have Ming-Yang
Song from Harvard
talking about precision screening for colorectal cancer.
So without further ado, I think we'll just get right into it.
We will have five minutes for Q&A after each of the presentations, and
then we'll have, hopefully, a little bit of time at the very end for a panel
discussion with the three of us. So,
happy to introduce Dr. Graham Colditz, who I'm sure many of you know.
Please come up, Graham. He is a professor at Washington
University School of Medicine in St. Louis. Thank you.
Thanks, Chris.
Thanks, and it's great to be here
in a pretty dynamic state of
risk and guideline changing in the space of breast
cancer. Acknowledge my
collaborators in thinking through the challenge of
a framework for precision
screening. In terms of conflict of interest here, I
do consult for Luna, who license our software
from WashU, and also obviously
still write for UpToDate.
So where are we? As Chris really just said,
I'll call it the sledgehammer approach, a very blunt
approach to screening at this
stage.
Despite decades of research
where fundamentally treating
risk is the same for everyone unless they're in a
very high-risk familial setting.
But even then, we know that it does reduce
mortality,
that there's pretty clearly
established access, at least in the US, from
40 onwards. Europe, pretty much
the rest of the world, follows 50 as a starting age,
although British Columbia starts at 40, so there is some
variation. But for the US, access is there,
and
radiology's got really well-developed pathways
for managing the outcomes of screening
reads.
Suzanne Fletcher really decades ago documented
some of the
consequences of the follow-up of positive reads,
indicating
maybe up to 50% a lifetime risk of
a workup from a positive read. And
so the challenge, I think, before us is that
we're really
managing risk
here at a population level, regardless of a
woman's individual risk. And yet
I think we can challenge the
audience, the world, that lower-risk women could be
screened less frequently, higher-risk women could
have
more frequent screening, more intensive follow-up.
And so we have the case for precision
screening based on
individual absolute risk.
And in fact, we've got
three trials here I know, and other studies in
Europe,
really trying to evaluate
different personalized screening strategies.
And the point of this is to already highlight
that there's no sort of common definition of when we're
going to call risk elevated enough to
go into a high-risk strategy. If you look across
the high-risk cut point, wisdom use
6% five-year risk, which is sort of double the
ASCO recommended cut point to begin the
discussion for endocrine therapy to reduce risk.
MAPEBES
used a composite no one cut point type of
definition, and the perspective trial out
of Canada is using lifetime risk, and their
25% lifetime risk is about a
3.9% five-year risk on average.
So right instantly, we're not
Consistent thinking through the
definitions, the intervals of screening and action
vary a little. So it's fair to say we have no
consistent
map of risk and screening
frequency, and that if we could standardize this, we would
help move the field forward. Now, there've been studies
arguing that we can screen less frequency,
low-risk women and save the NHS
dollars and get better outcomes for women.
But that's all based on an organized screening program, as
Europe runs, UK being, I don't know whether they want to be
called Europe, but they're part of that organized screening program.
You screen when the government says you can, and not
before. Thank you.
So CISNET used sort of the US
base case, if you will,
and back in January this year, published their
five-year absolute risk-based analysis,
to look at the trade-offs. They showed that
risk-based screening could actually improve
the numbers of breast cancer deaths averted by
screening, by focusing the screening at
the right risk levels and by reducing
screening in low risk, they reduced
the false positives by up to a quarter.
So good US-based
strategy, right? So conclude risk-based
screening improves benefits and reduces
harms.
Is the case closed,
or can you follow their algorithm for when we should start
screening?
They were doing this as an academic exercise, let's say.
So as you look across here,
there's no sort of one simple number for
five-year risk that says now you begin annual screening.
If you're
50 and at risk higher than 1.48, then
you qualify. But
if you're 60 at 1.23
five-year risk, so even there, we're not seeing
consistency and equally in their biannual
screening recommendation. So we've sort of got a nice
evaluation that shows us, yes, we can
improve outcomes, reduce mortality, and yes, we
can reduce adverse effects. But
I don't think this is quite ready for primetime
clinical implementation. So
do we really have clinicians and women
understanding age-based cut points if we're trying to
communicate a chart like that? Wouldn't it
be better to have some universal cut points and
ideally,
make these based on absolute risk,
let's say five-year risk, since that's something that we can
estimate. US
guidelines use five-year risk. FDA used five-year
risk to approve tamoxifen for risk reduction,
so let's stick with that as a framework
and let's do this sort of, if you will, model agnostic.
So we're not saying my model's better than yours and Gail's not as good as
Tyrer-Cuzick and getting ourselves distracted in a
battle over that type of detail. But think
if we've got a good measure of absolute risk, how do
we frame the screening,
starting and frequency to actually get to
that population benefit? So
we proposed to use
a fairly straightforward logic and
derive some cut points.
Started with the referent cut point
for
really the global
five-year risk to start screening, taking the risk
of a 50 to 55-year-old woman in the range of
1% to 1.5% five-year risk. So that
then becomes relatively applicable across
high-income countries. We then have
risk strata. The higher the risk may be more frequent
screening, even additional imaging, lower risk,
less frequent screening, and used a Poisson
regression to
set this all out. And
literally with this, any calibrated tool,
calibrated to the US incidence rate or in
Europe to a European country's incidence
rate could use the output to tie a screening
frequency to a level of risk.
The blue line here is the theoretical
screening interval, and obviously, we're not going
to recommend every five years as a starting point,
but it gives you a
flavor. If your risk is low enough, the algorithm
would say screening every five years would get you the same
benefit as a high-risk woman on the right-hand
side at
3% five-year risk in terms of cancers detected.
And so the consistency across here is that we've set
it up to find the same
number of cancers across a screening interval,
thatis driven by the incidence rate.
So translating that to our current US
guidelines, greater than 3% on this figure,
the 3% vertical line, Preventive Services Task Force
and ASCO cut point for discussion of endocrine
therapy to reduce risk. We'll say, okay,
that's your cut for annual
screening with the option of
supplemental imaging.
If you're 1.67,
which is the cut between the
initial FDA recommendation for increased risk for
endocrine therapy and the ASCO, so that middle
ground, we say that is the default
just for annual screening. And below
1.67, you would justify
the less frequent biennial screening.
So this is all then driven by the woman's risk, not just by her age,
her family history, or some other
measure of risk.
Clear advantage that we get fewer unnecessary
recalls, less radiation, longer intervals
for lower risk women. It frees our
capacity to meet the demand for more frequent screening in the higher
risk women, and hopefully would end up generating
more patient trust in screening.
For higher risk women, we get annual mammography and the addition
of supplemental imaging as indicated.
Earlier stage at detection should follow, which will give us better
prognosis. We identify the high-risk women
who can be offered counseling for
endocrine prevention.
Interval cancer should be caught earlier if we're
appropriately delivering annual screening, and
the mortality benefit
should follow beyond the universal strategies as
demonstrated by the CISNET
approach of evaluating the risks and benefits.
Now,
if we're thinking from the equity point of view, we know
we've, at the moment, got disparities in
outcomes for breast cancer, reflecting both
the racial differences in distribution of
triple-negative and other subtypes of breast cancer
and adherence to treatment. And so the
sense here is if we could get to a risk-based
screening, we would start to equalize the
potential for the detection of
cancer in the first place. So we've got risk
models. Talking this morning, I know of
image-based risk
as rapidly moving a systematic review just
out in JNCI 51 papers addressing
image-based risk models.
They should be validated in diverse
populations. Lots of work ongoing in that space.
Strategies to communicate risk
in acceptable language for women and also
for their providers who are not comfortable necessarily
in thinking of screening based on risk rather than just
age. This has got implications for
insurance and cost issues.
What used to be the CDC-run Breast and Cervical Screening
Program, hopefully that's still persisting.
Improving access to screening and
ideally, risk-based screening can get our resources to
align with the needs and better meet the
geographic reach of screening for women.
So where are the guidelines? This is a
rapidly moving challenge. Preventive Services
said with their '24 report and previously, the
risk models aren't good enough to justify risk-based screening.
Okay? Questionnaire tools, yeah, they
have error, and so we should stick with age
and family history. So again, anyone in the
room who's been studying risk factors for breast-- All for naught.
Age and family history is all we need according to
Preventive Services. We're not there.
Obviously, the trials are not consistent in even
defining the categories, and
NCCN just last month
moved ahead and said image-based risk
is sufficient. You can use Tyrer-Cuzick
questionnaire-based really driven by family history, or
you can use image-based risk. So image-based
risk is in the NCCN
breast screening recommendation,
and members of other panels are now
already saying to me, "We need to get our recommendations in line with
the screening. I'm on risk reduction," and so on.
But that is likely to move through the field.
Importantly, they're not all out there calibrated to
see incidence rates at this stage, which is one of the gaps
our model is, and that's sort of where the
field stands at the moment. And then on Friday, the College of
Physicians went back to, I don't know,
providers should talk to women about their risk at age
40Women with a dominant
genetic familial syndrome should start screening
early, and everyone else is average risk and should start
at 50. So again, all the other
models, all the insights on risk,
not worth considering unless you've got a personal
history, a dominant gene, or
actually had breast cancer yourself.
Everyone else just starts screening at 50.
So there is continuing,
shall we say, debate at the guideline level.
I think the evidence is clearly mounting that
risk-based screening can improve outcomes
and reduce the burden for
women of
what would be called false positives.
And so the field is ready to,
I think, move forward. So while there's no consensus in the
trials, we propose that incidence
risk-based model can be a
suitable way to translate for women, and
then that can be tailored to guideline cut
points in Europe, UK, wherever is
appropriate. CISNET certainly showed that the
risk-based screening would increase the savings
in breast cancer deaths and reduce the
workup of false positives. We propose a
common framework,
and so
feel that that gives us then a chance to bring guidelines,
hopefully around the world, to use a more consistent
strategy to guide the screening, and
the
goal to have a strategy that is
model-agnostic, then lets countries choose which models they
use rather than
necessarily being tied into one predefined
approach as could be the case if we took the
eligibility criteria for one of the trials and said, "Well, we better use
the exact same strategy to define
eligibility going forward." So with that, I
thank you, and I'm happy to take questions.
Yes, we have time for questions. Please go to the mics.
Go ahead.
Okay.
I think screening
assumes that there is no
metastasis happening before the tumor becomes
visible
on a mammogram,
and there is a certain number of months before
metastasizing actually happens.
So
are you aware that anybody has actually proved at what stage
a breast cancer
metastasizes?
And if, have anybody looked into how many months between
a tumor becomes detectable
and until it spreads? Because that should really be the
period of time you look for between
screenings.
So I hear you, and I know there are groups in
Sweden trying to model the rate at which the tumor
grows from initiation to being detectable,
and we've literally tried to get funding to
study which risk factors modify the rate of growth.
But at this stage,
I think there's the rate of growth you're describing.
There's also the risk of interval cancers,
which we know happen,
particularly in a two-year screening program.
Triple negative are more likely to pop out
in the two-year interval if we're at a two-year interval, and
women are at risk of triple negative that we don't have risk
factors for
in reality.
So there's another whole way, as you're describing, that could be driven
by a woman's density, which masks
detection, and the risk factors that could
modify how quickly a tumor's going to grow if it develops in
that woman.
The best I've seen is that's not ready for prime time, but it
would be absolutely a modification of this because
it would be driven by five-year risk and the risk of
an aggressive tumor being
detectable before the next routine screening. Yeah.
Thank you. It's just super interesting.
Hi. Thank you for a nice presentation.
Jack D'Abbene from the Ohio State University Wexner Medical Center.
Can you hear me okay?
That's better.
I can talk louder if you like. Okay, sorry.
So
I'm always fascinated by precision screening or risk stratification
just because
it's actually nice to hear that the progress we've done over
the years.
But it feels to me still the Holy Grail of screening, because it's very
hard to predict someone's risk in terms of how they would benefit
from screening. My question really is more about age
as a factor. So let's set aside the genetic risk factors,
BRCA, other genetic mutations that increase risk, can identify
women with those risk or any other cancer for that
matter.So,
when you talk about age and the other risk factors, to what extent do you
believe that
other risk factors could contribute
to risk stratification outside of age,
in terms of when thinking about how frequently you screen and as someone gets
older,
and the other factor, of course, is the screening history, right?
So if you've got a screening history, the negative tells some more information.
So I'm just wondering about age in relation to other risk factors.
I
think if we look to where the
breast image-based risk is going, age is
in that. So you've got the age of the woman and the
summary of her breast tissue
from the mammogram, and that is, in fact,
enough to stratify risk,
and absolute risk can then
be the driver. And that
persists across race, ethnicity of the
woman because the mammogram's actually summarizing the breast
tissue, which is where the cancer grows.
It's not modified by the
skin color. It might be modified by the risk factors, but we're
summarizing those in the breast tissue.
And so age
of the woman and the mammogram
together
give you an estimate of absolute risk.
So then
we can actually base the screening on that absolute
risk, not just on age.
So great talk. Susan Slager from the Mayo Clinic.
So I work in hematology, and we're developing approaches
for screening. But for breast cancer, how do you get these models
out to the community? You kept talking about the primary care physicians and stuff
like that.
So at Mayo Clinic, we're generally more informed, but the general
community
physicians, how do you get this
information out and to the women?
So
I think there are
challenges for women and primary care providers.
In colon screening back in the mid
1990s when colon screening was approved
by Congress for Medicare to cover, we
ran a program across New England to educate
primary care providers. Mass Medical Society mailed every
member of Mass Medical to make them aware of the value of
screening, what the options were, what age to start
screening. We had a major campaign through
media,
metro buses, trains, and so-
But your models are changing. That's a lot of work that you just did for-
Yeah
... a basic model, and now you're bringing in genomics and
mammography screening metrics and stuff.
Right.
So is that the only way?
Primary care docs,
to me, ACP saying you should talk to your primary care
doc about your risk at 40 to decide whether to start screening.
Well, they've got to either pick a tool
or say, "Go have a mammogram and let that drive
your risk."
And that to me is still, if you will, an education gap that
hasn't been solved because there's
no way every primary care doc's going to understand
Tyrer-Cuzick and implement it in primary care when
there's, what, two million women turning 40 every
year in the USA, right? There's too many
unknowns for primary care to reach all of them
annually.
Okay. I think we'll take just one more question, but then we will have time at the
end for hopefully panel discussion.
So maybe you can reserve your questions for then. Go ahead.
Peter Cecchini, Queen Mary University of London. Thank you very much.
I was just wondering whether we should be focusing on the risk of an
interval cancer or an advanced stage cancer node
positive on the next screen. I'm a little concerned that
just basing it on
five-year incidence may cause inequalities
because groups that don't participate in screening will have
lower age-specific risk because they don't get their
cancers diagnosed as early. And so you'll actually be
reinforcing those inequalities by saying your risk is
lower because you don't participate in screening or as a group you don't,
and therefore screening will be offered less.
But also if screening is finding a cancer whilst it's
still stage one on the next screen, there's no need to
shorten the interval.
Yeah.
I
hear the challenge of interval, and I
totally understand that in an organized screening program
as the rest of the world uses, that's very easy to
define. I'll challenge most people to
identify in screening,
which in the U.S. is opportunistic, women choose what
interval to come back and screening services record
or don't record how the cancer was
actually detected. Was it the woman's
self-referral or is it a two-year routine
screen? So we have a lot of trouble actually
answering that question with data in the U.S. at the moment.
But I hear you that going forward, there could be a
refinement to actually adjust for that.
And in a way it comes back to the first question that asked about the
rate at which tumors grow, and can we
identify the subset of women who are going to have
rapidly growing tumors versus the subset who are going to
have much more slowly growing and would be just fine with two or
three years screening to pick up an early-stage lesion.
Yeah.
Great.
Thank you.
Thank you,
Graham.Okay,
great. For this next-- okay.
Well, good afternoon, everyone. I'm going to be sharing some of our unpublished
work on our efforts to discover and validate novel blood-based
biomarkers to improve the early detection of breast cancer.
The work that I'm going to be presenting has largely been funded by NCI's
Early Detection Research Network, or EDRN for short.
I do not have any relevant disclosures.
So before I go into the details of our work, I think it's important to take a
little bit of a step back and talk about our overall approach,
because the development of blood-based biomarkers for really any kind of
context has historically been hampered by issues
related to reproducibility, and so it is critical to employ
rigorous study designs to be able to achieve our translational
goals. And very early on, when I started doing work in this space, I had the good
fortune of collaborating with Dr. Margaret Pepe.
She is a now retired biostatistician who spent decades working
at Fred Hutch. And she really led the development of
building out a robust framework for the evaluation of candidate biomarkers,
particularly in the cancer setting.
And her approach really continues to be the gold standard used by
EDRN investigators today. And while I scoured the internet, I could not find a
single photo of her online. I think that she would appreciate instead
me highlighting one of her seminal papers in this space that she
published back in 2008,
that again, laid out a number of these key principles that biomarker studies
need to follow. So the first thing is that this
framework is called the PROBE design, which stands for Prospective Specimen
Collection, Retrospective Blinded Evaluation.
And it really starts out by laying
that people who are designing these types of biomarkers
need to very clearly think through what are the potential clinical applications
that the biomarkers are intended for. What is the target population?
What is the setting in which patients would receive this test?
And what would be the outcome of interest that is being tracked?
And then once you have set out the clinical application, you can then define
what are the necessary performance characteristics in terms of sensitivity and
specificity that the test would need to have in order to achieve
the desired clinical utility.
She also really prioritized the use of what we call preclinical samples.
So these are samples that are drawn from healthy patients prior to their
diagnosis of cancer. In this field today, many people are
still using convenient sets of samples.
These are samples that are drawn from newly diagnosed cancer patients and then
compared to whatever sort of set of normal, healthy individuals that are
out there, and there can just be issues in the way those samples were collected
that lead to differences.
And so using rigorously collected preclinical samples
really mirrors the intended clinical application, because you're
using samples that are from patients who don't have clinically
detectable cancer at the time that the blood was drawn.
Of course, it's important to utilize rigorous study designs
and have stringent study protocols for the way that the specimens were
collected, processed, and stored, and then to use
laboratory tools that are both reproducible
and can be validated. We have also prioritized the use of
platforms where the volumes of samples that are required are small
because we're largely using very precious samples from various
prospective cohort studies, where we're only able to get very
small volumes of samples for testing.
And then depending on the context, it may be critically important to also
incorporate disease heterogeneity.
So the work that I'm going to present is on breast cancer.
I think we appreciate that there are major molecular subtypes of breast
cancer that have very different underlying biologies.
So we would fully expect then that the types of early detection
biomarkers for, say, luminal hormone receptor-positive breast
cancer might be completely different from those for
triple-negative basal-like breast cancer.
And so that's one way we've tried to account for this disease heterogeneity.
Another framework that Margaret developed that we are also using in our work
are these so-called five phases of biomarker discovery and validation.
Basically, biomarkers would have to pass each of these steps
sequentially in order to ultimately achieve clinical utility.
So it starts with Phase I studies, which are really preclinical
exploratory studies, all the way through to Phase V studies, which are generally
randomized controlled trials, where you're really evaluating the
efficacy
and efficiency of the particular test that you
have developed. The work that I'm going to be describing today are our results
with respect to Phase II and Phase III studies, and then also
our planned upcoming Phase IV prospective study.
So that's kind of what my talk will cover, is that scope of work.
So okay. So now kind of turning to
breast cancer and the work that we will be doing.
So I think as Graham clearly outlined, mammography is
widely utilized. It has been shown in randomized controlled trials
to reduce mortality by 30% among women 50 to
69 years of age.
But mammography has certain limitations.
Its positive predictive value is only 4.4%.
That does improve among older women.
But breast cancer screening remains an important public health challenge
because breast cancer remains the leading cause of cancer mortality among women
worldwide. So our goal is really to try to develop biomarkers that can
improve mammography's performance, and we've also already talked about some of the
areas for improvement. So one is that mammography has a relatively high
recall rate of 10%, meaning 10% of all women who go for screening
mammogram are asked to come back for a repeat testing of one type or
another. But only five out of every 100 women who come back for that
repeat testing are diagnosed with cancer.We also have talked about
this challenge of interval-detected cancers.
About 20% of breast cancers are detected in
that interval between
regular screening mammograms, and so this is certainly an issue.
And there also remain a number of other ongoing controversies with mammography in
terms of when to start screening, when to stop screening, and whether or not
certain
subgroups of women should be prioritized.
And Graham very nicely laid out a lot of these issues.
So for the work that I'm going to be talking about, we really focused on the age
range of women where there's sort of very little controversy, I would say, around
screening women 50 to 69. And we also know that in this age range,
about 80% of breast cancers that are diagnosed are hormone receptor positive, so we
really focused on developing biomarkers specific for hormone receptor
positive disease.
Okay. So, as Margaret had laid out for us, we needed to
define what our intended clinical application. So we have three of them.
In the interest of time, I'm only going to be talking about the first one, which is
to inform the timing of a subsequent mammogram in women who've had a negative
screening mammogram. So basically, a woman comes in, she has a mammogram,
it's negative. Can we then do a test that would say, "Okay, you're at high risk.
You should actually come back early for another screening mammogram in, say, six
months. You're at average risk. You can come back in one to two years, or maybe
you're very low risk, and you can come back more than two years later." So
that is kind of the application I'm going to be talking about today.
So we then had to define, well, what would be the necessary performance
characteristics for a test of this type to be useful?
And so, kind of forgive me in advance, but I'm going to kind of go through some of
the details of the math that's involved here.
This really started with saying, "Okay, among women 50 to
69, what is the annual instance rate of breast cancer for those who've just had a
negative screening mammogram?" It's about 0.3%.
So if we think about this context of early recall in six months, we can
assume that then the instance rate at six months would be
0.15%. So this is obviously a very low percent, but that's
what we can then base our calculations off of.
So given this context of a very low incidence rate and
the screening context, we decided that we wanted to have a test with
a very high specificity. In other words, a very low false
positive rate of only 5%. We then evaluated, okay, given
that very high specificity, what would we be able to detect with different levels
of sensitivity or true positive rate?
So at 35% sensitivity, we would detect 10 and a half breast
cancers for every 1,000 repeat six-month mammograms.
If we set it even lower to only 20%, we would detect six for
1,000 repeat six-month mammograms.
So what do these numbers mean?
Would this be good? Would this be bad? Is this helpful or not?
Fortunately, we have the context of mammography itself,
which
detects three and a half cancers for every 1,000 regular screening mammograms.
So actually, this level of performance actually exceeds the performance of
mammography itself. So we thought, okay,
if we're, again, setting this high specificity of 95%, we could actually
tolerate a test with relatively low sensitivity, even in the 20% to
35% range. So that was what we set as our desired minimally acceptable
performance for the test we wanted to develop.
So we then, again, going back to those PROBE principles, wanted to
select pre-clinical blood samples for our discovery and validation work, and we had
the good fortune of collaborating with two cohorts, Women's Health Initiative,
large prospective cohort of over 161,000 women, as well as the
Cardiovascular Health Study, a much smaller cohort that focused on individuals over
the age of 65.
Both of these cohorts were PROBE compliant in the ways that
they collected and stored blood samples, as well as their
central education of breast cancer outcomes, as
well as other available clinical data.
So basically, what we did is we applied a nested case control study design to these
cohorts, where we defined the cases as any woman who was
diagnosed with a hormone receptor positive breast cancer, who
had a blood draw within the two years prior to that cancer diagnosis.
And then we matched controls to those cases, who were
cancer-free women. We matched them on things like age, race, and
geography.
We then selected our biomarker discovery platform,
which is this antibody microarray platform developed by my colleague, Paul
Lampe, at Fred Hutch.
It's a platform where we basically print 3,000 different
antibodies on a single slide. I'm not going to go through all of the details.
And we can use it for both
identification of protein biomarkers, as well as autoantibody
biomarkers.
And so
one of the main advantages of this particular platform is also that it requires
very small volumes of samples. So only 25 microliters of plasma for the protein
array, and only one microliter of plasma for the autoantibody
array. And so we could look at both cases and controls in a pretty high throughput
manner, looking at 3,000 protein markers and then 3,000
autoantibody markers using these sample volumes.
We also wanted to make sure that this was a reproducible platform.
Here's just very quickly the coefficients of variance for the different markers
when we looked at them in triplicate.
And you can see that
all the CVs are generally less than 10% and that this didn't vary by the
abundance of the proteins.
So, this slide actually summarizes several years of work.
But what we wanted to do is to take all the different kind of
sets of samples that we had and then divide them into independent sets
of samples that we could then apply this framework
of biomarker discovery, confirmation, and validation.
So here you can see that we started our discovery work looking at all
3,000 markers in the protein setting in one of
our WHI, we call it WHI one set, where we had 121 cases,
121 controls. We then had kind of pre-specified statistical
criteria in terms of the sensitivity specificity that the markers needed to have in
order to pass through to the different confirmation steps, all the way through to
the final validation step, which was in the Cardiovascular Health Study
sample, 65 cases, 296 controls.
We ended up going from those 3,000 markers to 32 markers that we
were trying to validate in the CHS set.
We ended up validating six at P less than 0.05 and 10 at P
less than 0.1.From this particular set.
This is a very similar slide showing the same kind of pathway for our
autoantibody markers. Again, started with 3,000, ended with
12, validated five of those at P less than .05, and
seven
at P less than .1. So this slide
shows you our five best markers with the performance across each
of the three different preclinical sets.
So two protein and three autoantibody markers.
And you can see that all of these markers have been previously
implicated in cancer progression, metastasis,
or proliferation. So starting at the top, REG4
is known to promote breast cancer stem cell properties through the
Wnt/beta-catenin and EGFR/AKT pathways,
and has been specifically shown to be upregulated in breast cancer and to
promote proliferation and metastasis.
Next is JAK2, which is known to be involved in the
JAK-STAT signaling pathway, promotes cancer cell survival,
proliferation, resistance to apoptosis, and also has been implicated
in resistance to chemotherapy.
Those kind of looking at this table very closely will see that we use 80%
specificity rather than the 95% specificity for our
evaluation of these individual markers.
And this is because we never expected that one single marker would be able to
achieve the intended performance that we had.
And so we wanted to try to enrich the pool of markers that we had for those that
had reasonably high specificity in the hopes that then being able to put together a
panel of markers would enable us to achieve our desired level of
performance. So the next step then was to try to
integrate these markers to try to optimize the performance of the panel.
So this is the panel that maximizes the AUC.
You can see, though, here that we did not achieve the desired performance, 15%
sensitivity and 95% specificity.
But Margaret Pepe, throughout the many years I knew her, she always
complained that people are inappropriately using AUC.
Like AUC is not what we should be maximizing in this setting because
AUC is not relevant to our intended clinical application.
And we actually ended up publishing together a paper specifically describing why
the AUC is not the appropriate metric in this setting, and that instead of
trying to maximize AUC, we should design an ROC curve that
maximizes
sensitivity when you set 95% specificity.
And so that's what we did. This is
the AUC curve, our ROC curve, for then the
four-marker panel where we have maximized sensitivity at 95%
specificity. Certainly not as pretty as the one I just showed you, but we
only really care about the left side of this curve, and we are able to achieve now
this 50% sensitivity at 95% specificity,
exceeding what was our necessary minimal
performance. So this actually brings
us pretty close to where we are today.
So now that we have kind of identified our top-ranked validated markers,
we're working with Mesoscale Diagnostics to develop
high-quality,
clinical grade type of assays that could be used
to evaluate these markers more rigorously.
So we have already received the REG4 assay from them and have shown in our
hands that the CV is very low for this assay.
We have the other four markers coming into the lab in the next few months.
Once we have all of these assays in hand, we will go back to one of our original
WHI sets and evaluate them in those same set of samples just to
make sure that what we're finding in the MSD assays align with what we saw
in the original array-based platform.
Then we have reserved a completely separate set from
WHI. This is a larger set of 228 cases,
455 controls, and a unique aspect of this particular
WHI set is that we actually have blood from two time points collected
one year apart. So we'll be able to also look at the trajectory of these markers
over this one-year period, and we'll use this information to
refine what we're kind of calling our final combination
marker decision rule. We will then test this decision rule
in a new prospective cohort, the MD Anderson MERIT cohort, and I'll
describe this cohort in just a moment in a little bit more detail to describe.
This will be our phase four study, kind of going back to the framework I talked
about at the beginning. Something that I haven't talked about at all, just in the
interest of time, is that another major component of our EDRN
project is the integration of radiomic data.
So I'm working very closely with my colleagues Savannah Partridge and John
Hein, and this work has also been generously supported by a
team from Microsoft AI for Good, who's doing a lot of the computational work really
at no cost to us, where we have a large repository of
screening mammography as well as screening MRI images that we're
using to extract radiomic features to see how these features can also
further improve,
and add to the
blood-based markers that we're developing to help improve model performance.
So going back then to this MERIT study, this will be the next phase that
we hope to launch within this next year.
This is a prospective study being led by my colleague Sam Hanash, again at
MD Anderson. And a unique aspect of this cohort is that it
includes all of the imaging data. It has blood collected every
year. It has all of the questionnaire, medical record, health information
data that we can also use to help improve our models, and they already have
over 250 breast cancers that are diagnosed.
And so we're really excited about being able to kind of integrate our blood-based
work with our radiomic work in this cohort.
So
just to kind of summarize, our overall goal really is to try to improve
the efficacy and efficiency of breast cancer screening.
Our particular use case is women who've just had a negative screening
mammogram, having them take this sort of hopefully validated
risk prediction tool that will hopefully integrate blood markers, imaging markers,
maybe medical record information as well, and then provide them with information.
Should you come back in six months because you're high risk?
Are you average risk and come back at one to two years?
Or low risk, you might not need another mammogram for the next several years.
So that is kind of our vision of what we're hoping to accomplish.
So with that, just want to acknowledge the many people who've been involved in this
project, all of the members of the Lampi Lab who did all the laboratory work that I
described, Margaret Pepe, and many of the other statisticians at the Hutch who've
really helped ensure the rigor of this work.
My colleagues at MD Anderson and MSD who are going to be really critical for the
next phases of this project. EDRN, which has
supported... this work now for several years.
And of course, the participants in WHI and CHS, the generosity
of them to donate their blood as well as their data to research.
This work wouldn't be possible without that.
So thank you so much for your attention, and happy to take any questions.
Larry.
Hey. Hi, Chris Lee. Larry Kessler from University of Washington.
Really very clear, good presentation. Thanks.
I was wondering, because I think Professor Colditz, when he
referred to the NCCN change just last month, was referring to ,
I'm pretty sure it's the Clarity project from Connie Lehman and her team.
It's already gone through FDA and had been
granted market authorization. So I'm curious, is there a way for you to use what
you've done with blood complementary rather than reinvent the wheel?
I'm all fine-
Yeah
... with the AI for good people, but seems like we already have something
that tells us a lot about breast cancer risk after a woman's had a mammogram,
and your work could be quite complementary.
So the work that Microsoft has been working with us on is primarily with
the screening MRIs. And we will have MRIs for a number
of the women in the Merit cohort as well.
Because, yeah, for those that are high risk, there is greater...
And especially when you're at a tertiary center like MD Anderson or with us at UW,
that's why we have this very large cohort that Savannah's put together of screening
MRI patients over, I think, a few thousand patients.
And so that's the main aspect where there has not been as much done.
But I think there will certainly be opportunities to use those existing tools on
the mammography side in the Merit cohort and trying to
integrate with our markers as well.
And is there an advantage of using mammography-based prediction for
the next interval versus blood-based, or...
I think we're just trying to maximize the performance, so we'll see what
combination performs the best and that we can then validate to show clinical
utility.
Best of luck.
Thank you.
Yes.
So this is Hu Zhang from National Cancer Institute.
So my research focus a lot on studying the genetic
effects as difference across different breast cancer subtypes, especially for
intrinsic subtypes. So I'm wondering from clinical point of view, is there any
benefits if you trying to develop a specific prevention
strategy for more finer subtype within HR positive, such as
luminal A, luminal B, all this, or it's just too finer, it's not really
clinical useful?
I think we might expect the markers for luminal
A versus luminal B might have some variance. I think that's true.
And we're going to be tilted more towards the luminal A given the
patient populations that we have looked at.
That's generally older populations where luminal A is more frequent.
Another advantage of this
other Merit cohort is that it has a broader age range.
And so maybe we'll be able to see how it does in fact perform, if there's different
performance for across at least the luminal subtypes.
We have tried to do work also in triple-negative.
It's just, even in these very large cohorts like WHI, the number of patients
who then went on to develop triple negative, who have then these preclinical
samples, becomes very small. And so you might be able to do some
discovery, but then you really are very hampered on the validation side, is what we
have found.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi. Congratulations. Sherman, Mayo Clinic.
So we've just done what you would call a Phase I study in the 1
minus N, all the young people.
Uh-huh.
And
we in fact find differences by many factors.
Luminal A, luminal B-
Yeah
... tumor size, grade.
There's a lot of commonality-
Yeah
... at least for the autoantibodies in luminal A and B, but there are
some differences. So, it may be worth-
Yeah
... thinking about that as our colleague just suggested. Thank you.
Thank you. Yeah, thank you.
It's very interesting. I wondered if you
would tell us a little bit about how you measure your blood markers,
what type of assay, and if you imagine it can be done on
huge automatic
machines, or how it's going to be done.
Right.
So what we used for our discovery work was this array-based platform.
It's nothing close to a clinical-grade assay.
It really is meant for high throughput screening of, in this case,
thousands of different protein markers.
That's why we use those subsequent filtering steps.
That sort of platform would never be
clinically viable, and that's why we have made this partnership with
MSD, Mesoscale Diagnostics, to really develop.
Now that we have the biomarkers that seem to perform the best across multiple
sets,
we have now invested in developing these clinical-grade assays with a commercial
partner
to try to realize that clinical utility.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Do you think the biomarkers are made by the cancer cells or by
surrounding cells?
I don't know if we will know the... We don't know the answer to that, for sure.
Yeah. We'll see. I'm excited
about being able to do this other validation within the WHI set, where we
have the multiple time points to see, is there a trajectory, or is
it more of a risk marker, or is it more of an early detection marker where the
trajectory of the marker is going up, or is it just being flat as more of a risk
marker? So that might give us some clues, but again, it's kind of beyond the
scope of this work to really understand all the mechanistic side of it.
Super interesting.
Thank you.
Okay, maybe... Oh, do you have another question?
Yeah. Thank you. Well, just a comment and a teaser.
Yes.
So, for example, in triple-negative breast cancer,
my ESO1 antibodies are 10 to the minus 11.
Yeah.
Our study.
Maybe not surprising if you do cosmosFor
single-cell RNA on triple-negative breast cancers, you can see
the immune infiltrate around the NY-ESO-1
positive cells and not the negative cells.
And for example, the positive cells with high-- The cases
with positive and high immune infiltrate have a better
prognosis than the negative ones.
So if you can get your hands on those tumors, I think it would be very
cool to look at that. So, yeah.
Thank you so much. I think we'll-- And then, sorry.
In the interest of time, we'll move on.
We'll have, hopefully, time in the panel for your question.
My pleasure now to introduce our third speaker, Dr.
Mingyang Song, who is in the Harvard School of Public Health. Welcome.
Thank you, Chris, for the introduction and for having me.
It's my great pleasure to introduce our work and
some thoughts on precision screening for colorectal cancer.
So this is my disclosures. Following two great talks on breast
cancer, I do want to start by highlighting what makes colorectal
cancer, CRC, special for screening and also
precision screening. So CRC has very well
characterized the natural history from normal
mucosa to polyps, including adenoma and
serrated polyps, and then to cancer.
The whole process can take several decades, and this long
latency period really opens a huge window for early
detection.
And also,
different from all other screening tests that have been already recommended
clinically, colonoscopy is the only test
that have both early detection and prevention
benefits. In other words, the test can not only detect
early-stage cancer, but it can actually prevent cancer
by removing precursors, the so-called polyps.
So that's why for colonoscopy, we can say it not only
reduces mortality, but also incidence.
On the other hand, we know colonoscopy is very costly and
is invasive, and it can carry
substantial complications despite
the rare prevalence.
And also, colorectal cancer has very well characterized
risk factor profiles. So this has led to numerous
risk assessment tools trying to
stratify patients for tailored screening.
So here, I'm just show one example from a study that we
did a few years ago looking at various risk
factors of colorectal cancer. And when we summarize these
risk factors by calculating the risk score, we can say
compared to individuals with the lowest risk, those with the
highest risk score had almost a
threefold increased risk of colon cancer.
And we can say these risk factors do not even consider age
and sex, which are two other major risk factors for
CRC.
And on the other hand, GWAS studies in the past few decades have
identified hundreds of common genetic
variations,
and these
variants have been used to create a polygenic risk
score that has shown modest accuracy in
differentiating colon cancer from controls.
And this effort has been spearheaded by our colleagues at Fred
Hutch, Dr. Ricky Peters and Lee Xu.
And also, you probably have heard about the increase of
early-onset colon cancer in comparison with the
decline among older adults. So this has
created a huge opportunity for risk-based
screening or precision screening.
However, here, I do want to note that when we look at the absolute
risk for people under age 50, their absolute
risk is about 15 times lower
compared to people aged at least 65.
So when we think about
starting screening
early to prevent early-onset cancer, we do have to take
the absolute risk into account, just as Graham laid
out for breast cancer.
And because of the rise of early-onset colon cancer, currently,
the colonoscopy screening guideline has been
modified to start at age 45 instead of 50.
So, this figure really shows the current standard of
care. As Chris mentioned, it's still a
one-size-fits-all approach. So average risk adults
at the age of 45 would be recommended to undergo
colonoscopy screening. And here we are talking about average risk
individuals, not talking about people with a family history or with
genetic syndromes.
And
depending on the outcome of the colonoscopy,
for people with negative tests, they will be asked to repeat the colonoscopy
in 10 years, whereas for those with polyps, they will be put on
surveillance at different intervals depending on the severity of the
polyp. Of course, for people with cancer, they will undergo standard
treatment.
Also, I want to point out there are other
screening methods available for colorectal cancer.
These tests have also been recommended by clinical
guidelines with shorter intervals.
And this is another huge topic that I will not discuss
today, but I just want to emphasize that for people who are
tested positive on these non-invasive screening
methods, they will still be asked to receive a
colonoscopy to confirm the diagnosis and also to remove
the precursors. So regardless of what test you do,
if you are tested positive, colonoscopy is still
neededSo ideally, what we want to see
is
people with higher risk are
more likely to get a screening.
So this is the ideal situation. However, when we look at the
reality, the data, we can see that using the risk
score that I presented earlier,
we saw that individuals with the lowest risk score are actually
most likely to receive screening, indicating that people who are
generally healthy
and potentially socioeconomically more
advantaged are actually more likely to receive a
colonoscopy compared to the high-risk individuals.
So this created a mismatch of screening use versus
individuals' risk profiles.
And this can have substantial implications.
Like for people with low risk, there can be over-screening,
over-diagnosis of
precursors, like polyps, especially given the
improved quality of colonoscopy,
and we are picking more and more small and really benign
polyps. And there can be wasted resources
at the societal level, especially nowadays, the
colonoscopy capacity is already very limited in the clinic.
And when we look at the high-risk individuals, they are under-screened,
and their cancers can be
missed for early detection, and they will also miss the
opportunity for prevention.
So the goal of precision screening and surveillance is really to
correct that mismatch, so that
instead of asking everyone to start a screening at age 45,
we can tailor the starting age of screening depending on the risk
profiles of the patients. And also for patients
with really low risk, they may undergo
stool-based test instead of colonoscopy, at least
as the first-line screening. And also after
screening, we can also tailor individuals' surveillance
for colonoscopy to better align with their
CRC risk.
So in the next few minutes, I just want to present some work that we have done
to really test the
potential of precision screening at different points.
So first, starting with the starting age of colonoscopy.
So we used the data from the Nurses' Health Study, Nurses' Health Study
2, and Health Professionals Follow-Up Study, where we have collected
very detailed dietary, lifestyle information, as well as
screening use every two to four years over the past few
decades. And using the cohort data, we looked at
individuals'
10-year cumulative instance of CRC according to
age. So here, the gray line shows the
risk among all participants. So we use that as a benchmark.
And when we were doing the study, the recommended age of
initiating screening was still 50 years old.
So we used age 50 as a benchmark. We can see that for the
very high-risk individuals, those with the highest risk score,
they reached the
benchmark risk at age 44, indicating that they
may need to start screening six years
earlier than the general population.
Whereas, for the very low-risk individuals, they didn't reach this
risk until age 56. Again, indicating that they can
delay their screening for six years.
So this just provides some proof of principle that we
can indeed kind of tailor the starting age of
screening according to individuals' risk profiles.
What about individuals who are tested negative at a
colonoscopy? So again, the current guideline is to
repeat the colonoscopy in 10 years.
And we looked at our data, again, using the Nurses' Health Study and
Health Professionals Follow-Up Study data.
We compared individuals with a negative colonoscopy screening versus
those with no colonoscopy. We can see that the
lower the risk of CRC persists for up
to 20 years. So this figure shows the multivariable adjusted
relative risk according to years after negative screening.
So even at 20 years after screening, we can still
see the lower the risk of colonoscopy among those who are
tested negative. And we saw similar trend for CRC
mortality as well. Although there is a
slight increase at 20 years compared to 15 years.
But overall, there is still substantial reduction of
mortality even at 20 years after negative screening.
And when we further look at the
risk profiles among those individuals who are tested
negative, we can still see there is still considerable
variations in the cumulative instance of CRC,
again, using the similar risk score that I showed earlier, but now
including age and sex. We can see that if we
say for individuals who are at a very high risk to
repeat a colonoscopy in 10 years, and for those with
very low risk, they may not reach the same risk level
until 25 years, indicating that the screening interval
can be extended substantially, like up to 25 years
for the very low-risk individual.
So
even among individuals who are tested negative, who are
already at a very low risk of developing colon cancer, there is still
room for precision
modification.So what about individuals with
polyps? So currently in the clinic,
there's already some kind of precision
implemented. So the current recommendation is based on
the histopathology of the polyps, including
number, size, and histology of the polyps.
So individuals with different types of polyps would be recommended to
undergo colonoscopy surveillance at different intervals.
However, when we look at the quality of evidence, most of the recommendations
are based on very low or modest evidence.
So this has created a lot of confusion for both patients
and physicians. So to look at how colonoscopy
surveillance is being used in the clinic, we
assembled this Mass General Brigham colonoscopy cohort.
Basically, we pooled all the patients who have received a colonoscopy
in our hospital system between 2007
to 2023, and we collected
all the detailed EHR data, including colonoscopy and pathology.
And when we look at individuals with high-risk polyps and look at
their use of surveillance, we can see that only
64% of patients with high-risk
polyps actually received the surveillance.
And when we compare the surveillance use according to the
clinical guidelines, the compliance in terms of the interval of the
surveillance is only 21%. So this
indicates there is a substantial underuse of surveillance among
high-risk patients. And some other studies have shown
that among individuals with low-risk profiles,
there is overuse of surveillance.
So currently,
surveillance is very poorly delivered in the
clinic.
So we asked the question, how can we do better?
What other factors can help risk stratify patients to
better characterize the risk of post-colonoscopy CRC?
Of course, the obvious factors to consider would be the established
risk factors.
So we did a study trying to combine
the epidemiologic factors with the
histopathological features of
the polyps, and we identified these predictors
associated with post-colonoscopy CRC in our
cohorts, and then we validated the model in the Mass General
colonoscopy cohort. And we showed that a substantial
percentage of patients can be reclassified
using the new risk score compared to the current clinical practice,
compared to the current clinical guidelines.
And what about genetics? Like I showed earlier, polygenic risk score
has been shown to predict colon cancer.
But what about
patients who have already done a colonoscopy?
Can genetics still predict the risk?
So our hypothesis is that genetics can capture
the inherent risk of patients. So some people may
just have the high genetic susceptibility that would still
predispose them to higher risk of CRC despite the
use of colonoscopy.
And when we look at our data, that's indeed the case.
As we can see here, the polygenic risk score is
strongly associated with higher risk of CRC among
individuals who have received a colonoscopy.
So similar results are found in our nurses' cohorts and the UK
Biobank.
And when we look at the polyp recurrence in the MGB
colonoscopy cohort, we saw a similar trend, although the effect
size is much smaller.
So indicating the benefit of polygenic risk score.
And we can see the AUC also improved
to a modest degree when we add the PRS to the
polyp findings in the prediction model.
And also, quality of colonoscopy has been shown
to be very important for patients' risk, because if
we want to make sure patients have
their lesions are
completely detected and removed, we want to have really
high-quality exams. And it has been shown that the poor
quality can lead to missed or incompletely
resected lesions, and that's a major contributor to the
post-colonoscopy CRC, the so-called interval cancers.
And we showed in our MGB colonoscopy cohort that's
indeed the case. As you can see from the Kaplan-Meier curves,
among patients who are tested with high-risk polyps, we
can still see a substantial separation according to the
ADR, the physician's adenoma detection rate, which is an
established indicator of colonoscopy quality.
So patients who have
high-risk polyps and also who have their exams done by a
physician with low ADR, these patients have the
particularly high risk of developing CRC in the
next few years. We can say the 10-year cumulative instance
is about
over a threefold difference between
the
ADR Q1, the quartile one, versus ADR quartile four.
And the similar findings were found for
patients with low-risk polyps and no polyps as well.
So after showing you that
there is enormous opportunities for precision
approaches at different points,
either at the starting of screening or
after screening is completedSo what are the
challenges? So the first challenge is that
currently, the existing risk assessment tools
still have
suboptimal accuracy in predicting CRC.
And as I showed earlier, the PRS has an AUC of
around a .63, and our epidemiological factors
also have a modest AUC in the prediction.
And this has led to uncertain cost-effectiveness.
So this is a study done by Dr. Iris
Lansdorp of Vogelaar in the Netherlands,
where they looked at the cost-effectiveness,
comparing risk-based screening versus uniform
screening. We can see that with AUC of
.65 for the risk assessment tool,
the risk-based screening has a very modest benefit
compared to the uniform screening.
And there are some other challenges from the
implementation side. So for the risk assessment tool, we
really need high efficiency and also easy to use.
And we need the buy-ins from both patients and providers.
We want to make sure the risk assessment wouldn't add additional
burden to both parties.
And also, there has been concerns about unintended
consequences.
I think Graham already touched on this for breast cancer, and
similar concerns also apply to colorectal cancer.
So the precision approach may decrease the overall
screening use
because of the complexity of the algorithms and the
implementation. Also, there is always the
concern about the
worsened disparities. So again, the more
advantaged groups are more likely to
utilize the risk-based screening
approaches.
So
after talking about challenges, what are the opportunities
for the future?
First, we have learned from this conference that AI has
really
enhanced a wide range of research
across cancer care. And for screening, that's
particularly useful. Like AI can help us
automate data collection and processing, and also potentially help
improve the model performance by really taking into account
the complex data structure.
And also, we have more predictors available now.
So in addition to EHR, genetic testing are more commonly
done in the clinic. There are also the variables, mobile devices
that can be more accessible now in the
clinic.
And also, omics biomarkers also provide an opportunity to
capture the life course exposures.
Because one of the challenges with the existing risk assessment tool
is that it only
get a snapshot of individuals' exposures.
It doesn't really capture the life course kind of exposure.
So some biomarkers, such as microbiome and epigenetics, have
been shown to have some early imprinting effect.
So that can capture the early life exposures to better characterize
individuals' risk profiles.
So in summary, there are both scientific and practical
premises for precision colonoscopy screening and surveillance at
different points.
And currently, the top or the most
important or most
challenging kind of issue is still
the risk assessment tool. So we need a tool that has high
accuracy, efficiency and also acceptance.
And on the other hand, AI-related technologies and omics
biomarkers offer new promises and opportunities.
So with that, I would like to thank all my lab members, collaborators, as
well as funding sources. And finally, I was asked
to include this slide to help advertise
our cancer prevention research conference that's going to happen in Atlanta
in June. So after this AACR meeting, if you want to learn more
about cancer prevention, please come join us in
Atlanta. This is co-sponsored by American Cancer Society
and the CRUK. And with that, I want to thank you for your attention.
Happy to take any questions.
Great talk. This is more a question for the panel because I think it applies to all
three.
I understand why the siloed approach to
developing biomarkers and models for each of these, but I think as
we move into the era of precision screening, I think there's much
more of an issue of competing demands.
And so I think particularly as you try to apply these in clinical
settings, when you approach an individual
patient and an individual clinician, how do you
have them weigh the differential impact of precision
screening for a whole panoply of conditions that may
ultimately impact their health?
Okay. That's a great question. That's definitely a
huge kind of
question for the whole field. I feel like when we talk about a
precision screening or precision prevention, we do have to
look at each disease separately. As
you have seen from the talks, breast cancer has very different
issues from colon cancer, and we do have to take a
precision perspective when we start thinking about these
issues. For colon cancer, specifically, like I presented, I
feel like we have to look at different kind of scenarios.
For patients who are tested negativeWith colonoscopy,
especially with very high-quality colonoscopy, their risk is
so low that additional screening wouldn't
add much.
So I feel like that's the top area where we
can do more in terms of precision screening.
And for those patients with polyps, we can also do
some precision
stratification based on patients' profiles.
I guess the challenge is to collect the data
and to get the algorithm run and implemented in the clinic.
I feel like that's going to be the future.
I don't know what Graham and Chris
think.
Yeah, I think the clinical implementation is always the hardest part,
honestly.
I think at this point, we're still trying to even validate either the models, the
markers, the approaches that we're proposing to say, "Would they
have potential benefit?" And then the challenge of implementation
is one that can be taken on more vigorously.
Not a great answer, but that's, I think, where we're at, is still even just proving
the proof of concept, right? Still.
Other questions for either Dr. Song or panel?
Anyone who
had a question earlier that didn't have time?
Hi, this is Damon Jia from Vanderbilt.
I have a question for Dr. Lee. So
I know that multiple
protein-wise study have identified some
blood plasma biomarker, like protein or
metabolites related to, for example, breast cancer.
So in your study design, have you ever considered using this
prior
knowledge to
pre-screening some biomarker first?
That's my question.
Yeah. When we initially put together
the 3,000 targets that we were looking at from the beginning, we did try to
select for different pathways that were relevant to breast cancer based on what was
published. Some of it was also just convenience of what antibodies were available.
So we did try to do that. Others are using other strategies, using
more even humanized mouse models to try to
identify markers that way. So there's a number of--
We're not the only group, obviously, doing this, and there's many different
strategies that are being taken to try and identify promising markers.
It's just nothing has actually
reached the point of clinical utility yet, at least in the breast cancer space.
Thank you. I have one more question for Dr. Song.
So,
as you mentioned, the quality
of the colonoscopy or the surgery is a risk
factor. But in the real study, how do
we derive or measure the quality of previous
surgery for
patient? Patient doesn't know whether they have a good or
poor surgery from a good doctor or a bad doctor.
Yeah, that's a very good question.
So first of all, in terms of quality assessment in the
clinic,
I think many hospitals now have the quality improvement
program where they would monitor each physician's
performance on monthly or even weekly
basis, and to provide the feedback to the physicians
trying to really improve the quality.
And regarding patients, I think that's a very
good question. I don't have the good answer.
I was actually considering a colonoscopy for myself because of family
history. And when I was talking to my GI doc, I was trying
to get a sense about her experience or
how skillful she
is in terms of her performance. I feel like this
is
probably a bigger question
from the healthcare service perspective, like how
can we ensure that
patients are informed of the physician's
quality of performance, and also to ensure that
the information gets delivered in a
very transparent and also clear way.
I feel like that's going to be important.
And also, I do want to say, regarding the quality, I feel like
it's a very interesting point.
On the one hand, we do want the colonoscopy to have really high quality.
On the other hand, there is a concern about over-diagnosis, right?
Nowadays, AI has been widely used in colonoscopy.
There is the computer-aided colonoscopy that can
help physicians better spot the polyps
and
other precursors. So,
with the
improvement in the technology, we are going to
have diagnoses of some
benign polyps that would probably never
progress into cancer in the
patient's lifetime. Right? So that's always a
balance. We want better quality of care, but on the
other hand, we have to be mindful of the over-diagnosis.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'll keep it very quick. So I'm Bun Hong.
I'm from Malaysia, so I technically does mostly
on stats and also new in health economic.
So I'm looking into breast cancer as well as colorectal cancer.
It's generally for all three, anyone can answer this.
So I'm actually looking at what's the best
way to deploy screening to the population in Malaysia, because currently we don't
have a systematic screening in place for any cancer.
It's opportunistic in nature.So, when I look at
breast cancer, there's a lot of models.
So there's a wide range of models, and there's different combinations from a very
simple HP's mammogram, and you can go as complex as we have genetics
and lifestyles and so forth. So, and the performance varies.
Again, I agree sensitivity and specificity is the best way to define the
performance. That depends on the threshold that you apply to your population.
But for the question today, I'm going to use AUC.
So if you look at the published results when it comes to different
combinations of the models, the performance varies between from 0.5, then goes
up to 0.75 or even 8.0. So there's a wide
range in terms of performance, and I do
think that this might also impact when you actually run a simulation in a
population if you were to deploy a screening using a specific model.
If there's a difference in terms of accuracy, how much would that impact in
terms of the false positive rates?
Or even how much of a death is even prevented?
So I'm just curious, because I'm at the stage where I'm trying to
decide which model I should use. And
in a low-middle-income country, I believe there's two factors that I have in mind.
One is the cost, and second is in terms of accuracy.
It comes back to as they were asked, whether using age is enough
or using a simple model, just mammogram with family history is enough, or do you
have to consider genetics? And how much of this wide range of AUC
actually can impact the outcome that we are looking at in terms
of quality of life or, and et cetera? That's all my question.
On this set of issues, more than anyone that
I like to read,
Carl Moons from the Netherlands talking
about,
is our model impacting clinical
decision-making, patient satisfaction, and
population outcomes? And to frame
everything around that sort of starts to answer several of
these questions.
Are we actually improving the outcome at the
clinic or population level?
And let that drive the trade-offs, the
base case, and what might be valuable to add or not.
Anything to add? No.
Yes. Thank you for the question. I agree with Graham.
And on the AUC side, I think Chris mentioned this, is
AUC
really the best measure to use when we want to evaluate
the impact of precision approach at the
population level, and especially when we try to compare
different approaches, right? Compare risk-based screening versus
uniform screening. I had the question to
my modeling colleagues, who are running cost-effectiveness
analysis.
I was wondering whether we should use some reclassification measure
instead of AUC to better represent
the issue that we are looking at. It's not just a prediction,
it's actually a risk
stratification. Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you so much. I know we've just run out of time for this session, so thank you
all for attending.
Patience and attention.
Thank you.